elle voulait se faire refaire les fesses
et se fait amputer les bras et des
jambes c'est de quoi est ce plan il
s'embrasse sans pied s'il y a bien une
chose qu'on va plus regarder c'est son
cul
et maintenant le meilleur de Gaspard
Proust
pas une semaine sans que l'islamisme ne
fasse la une la dernière fois j'allume
ma télé tu vois je tombe sur un imam fou
en train de prêcher en fait c'était
Diane
non mais je veux pas la critiquer moi je
la préfère musulmane que rappeuse
tourisme alors je sais pas si tout le
monde a vu cette photo de kim jonga
Mahjong 2 ou backgammon 3 je sais plus
très bien
mec il est fort faire croire au monde
entier qui va lancer une attaque
nucléaire alors qu'il fait du cheval en
Camargue c'est
franchement c'est pas avec cette photo
qui fera trembler le monde enfin on
dirait Attila avec des problèmes de
cholestérol c'est pas
la Corée menace d'attaquer les
États-Unis la Corée les États-Unis alors
ils ont envoyé Denis Rodman grand
basketteur là pour pour faire une
médiation je comprends que les coréens
se vexent quand l'Amérique envoie comme
représentant officiel un ancien
basketteur habillé comme un dictateur
zaïrois enfin je même nous on n'a pas eu
l'idée d'envoyer Philippe Katerine
négocier avec ACMI
[Rires]
elle voulait se faire refaire les fesses
et se fait amputer les bras et des
jambes de quoi est ce plan il s'embrasse
sans pied s'il y a bien une chose qu'on
va plus regarder c'est son cul
[Applaudissements]
une ligne de bijoux style esclave a été
lancée enfin moi j'étais extrêmement
content mais évidemment ça fait
polémique dans ce pays tout de suite
c'est très mal vu d'être à la fois
soumis et coquet
alors c'est sûr bien sûr que
l'esclavagisme ce n'est pas bien c'est
vrai c'est vrai que c'est un vivre
ensemble qui ne laissait que peu de
place au dialogue social entre employé
et patron
après on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais
eux au moins ils avaient un travail
justice qui paraît que Cahuzac était en
soupçonnable
un chirurgien esthétique directeur de
clinique privée qui a une société de
conseil pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
et qui prend sa carte au PS dire comme
un disque de suspicion il faut quoi en
plus
alors je précise la PNL moi je suis
Suisse et j'ai un compte en France et je
fais déjà l'objet d'une enquête en
Suisse mais pas de la part des services
fiscaux mais des services psychiatriques
je dis ça de payer mes impôts ici parce
que je trouve ça formidable je pense
c'est super important de participer à
l'effort de redressement dans la justice
dans l'égalité du mariage pour tous we
are the world we are the childing et
parce que attention excusez-moi mais
d'être un peu engagé mais c'est vrai que
l'impôt ça sert à payer des hôpitaux des
crèches des écoles mais aussi des trucs
bien comme les prisons les charters la
bombe nucléaire des CRS qui viennent à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes quand on voit ce
qui te tracasse le gouvernement en ce
moment c'est quoi c'est les punks chiens
qui font des cabanes sur des tarmacs
quand j'achète
l'impression de voir le rassemblement
annuel des sosies de Zaz
ça c'est du sujet quoi ça c'est du sujet
quoi faire des tables rondes avec des
terroristes Nature et Découvertes
des tables rondes des cagettes retournés
moi le côté SDF des bois sans douche
fixe je sais pas quoi je sais de quoi je
parle ça une fois je suis sorti avec une
altermondialiste chacun c'est dossiers
bon le seul côté pratique avec une
altermondialiste que pour les mycoses
t'as pas besoin de passer au labo ça se
voit
[Rires]
justice ouverture du procès de
Jean-Claude masse l'ex droit des
prothèses mammaires frauduleuses 300 à
400 femmes sont venues assister au
procès quoi dès qu'il s'agit de
coquetterie quand il y a tout le monde
c'est pas au procès de clause Barbie
qu'on aurait vu une telle concentration
alors elles sont là chouineo il est
indifférent il s'en fout d'où le méchant
il fait qu'il fasse quoi qu'il arrive
rigolard salut les prothèses qui fument
bien sûr je suis coupable j'ai mis du
mazout mais au prix du brut j'allais pas
mettre du kérosène
contre la délinquance dans ce pays on a
tout essayé mais pas la charia
non parce que si on commence à couper un
bras à chaque délinquant en terme de
réinsertion à part faire Captain crochet
dans la parade chez Mickey
et encore je pense pas au multi
récidiviste eux ils n'auront qu'une
possibilité de réinsertion
les hommes troncs qui rebondissent dans
les filets
quelques bonnes nouvelles quand même le
mariage gay est devenu le mariage pour
tous
enfin pouvoir officialiser avec ma mère
[Applaudissements]
le plus dur ça sera d'annoncer à mon
frère que c'est aussi mon fils
tu connais la dernière blague de c'est
un député qui fait les marchés le
dimanche et il dit aux gens mais vous
savez on fait vraiment tout pour lutter
contre le chômage et tout et les
lecteurs qui répond
occupez-vous plutôt du mariage gay
[Applaudissements]
terminons sur une bonne nouvelle Michaël
Youn a encore été cambriolée avec un peu
de chance pour le cinéma les voleurs
auront aussi dérobé les scénarios des
prochains films
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu